voici à quoi ressemblait une
manifestation du 1er mai en 2010 et
voici à quoi elle ressemblait en 2009
2010 la différence c'est la violence qui
a paru dans les cortèges et notamment à
l'avant de ce site mais alors pourquoi
est-on passé de manif tranquille à des
batailles rangées et pourquoi les forces
de l'ordre n'arrivent pas à les
contrôler la première question est de
savoir comment on en est arrivé là
la raison principale c'est l'apparition
ou la présence de plus en plus de
casseurs à l'avant des manifestations et
parmi eux des blacks blancs et cela fait
suite à la perte de vitesse des
syndicats au début des années 2010 les
syndicats avaient encore un important
service de sécurité à la vente des
cortèges et ce n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui moi j'ai travaillé des
années en liaison étroite notamment la
cgt on s'accorde bien avant il y avait
un service d'ordre qui était très
efficace très costaud je le dis depuis
quelques années j'irai une dizaine
d'années à peu près des services d'ordre
se sont un peu délité parce qu'il
recrutait chez les dockers et assécher
les sidérurgistes et recrutés dans des
décors de métiers qui sont un peu moins
présent maintenant et il ya une crise
aussi la vocation à dents les syndicats
dont que les services d'ordre sont un
peu un peu moins moins présents il ça
laisse plus d'espacé plus d'oxygène à
ceux qui veulent casser l'autre point de
bascule s'intitule lors des premiers
actes des filets jaunes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les manifestants qui connaissait un peu
les règles de la manifestation jusqu'en
2018 savait qu'il fallait pas se frotter
aux forces de l'ordre et les forces de
l'ordre savait qu'il ne fallait pas se
frotter il y avait une espèce de no
man's land entre les manifestants et les
émeutiers les vies des jeunes n'étant
pas habitués à manifester eux sont venus
au contact des forces de l'ordre et cela
a eu le résultat que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui au tout départ les chances
de leur date est complètement désemparé
et les casseurs et les gilets jaunes
coller aux forces de l'ordre
et tout ça dans les rues de paris et ça
donnait lieu et samedi et des week-ends
dantesque que tout le monde garde en
mémoire
alors pourquoi les forces de l'ordre ne
vont pas interpeller directement ces
manifestants violents eh bien parce que
ce n'est pas facile
ils sont sur une ligne de crête au
niveau de l'interpellation c'est à dire
que si l'interpellent trop tôt on va
dire que ils se font de la provocation
policière et ils interprètent des
innocents et donc c'est tout à fait
contre productif en terme de main
ternois ce qui me donne beaucoup il va
par une partie du cortège qui va se
retourner contre eux il s'y attende trop
les black blocks qui sont vains va
arriver à 100 en quelques minutes et
tout d'un coup un service de sécurité
peut se retrouver à 100 types centaines
de personnes masquées près en décours
parfois armés ayant des techniques de
combat assez affûté donc
et là tout d'un coup le rapport de force
peut tourner au désavantage
[Musique]
alors que faire selon les experts de la
question
plusieurs réponses peuvent être
apportées déjà sur le plan de
l'organisation des forces de l'ordre
après les premiers actes d gilet jaune
une nouvelle doctrine du matin de
l'ordre a été mise en place avec
l'apparition des braves m
des unités mobiles sauf que si elle
permettre d'interpeller rapidement
elles vont aussi des défauts qui rit
sensibles ainsi que vous verrez beaucoup
moins l'image des gens mobiles et crs
ainsi ce sont des professionnels donc
qu'ici chic moins de problème ou moins
de problèmes avec eux il se met en
difficulté contrairement à ces deux
unités de police qui se sont isolés un
qui se mettent dans des situations dans
lesquelles ils subissent des attaques à
partir de gens qui donnent eux c'est pas
la preuve on maintient l'heure n'est pas
si les sous prétexe mobilité sont isolés
souvent un rapport de force très
défavorable
on est obligé d'être finalement beaucoup
plus virulent qui veulent sonnerait
voilà face à des gens qui payent et puis
selon espère des progrès peuvent être
faits au niveau de la coordination il ya
des phénomènes de désordre
d'incohérences tactique avec des unités
qui qui ne comprennent pas la présence
d'une autre à leurs côtés et c'est très
très confus actuellement sur le terrain
pour eux le problème viendrait d'une
trop grande centralisation du
commandement le problème c'est que -
quasi impossible de garantir une
cohérence tactique à partir une salle
opérationnelle qu'elle dispose que de
caméras mais qui n'a pas la vision
directe immédiate de ce qui se passe sur
le terrain et donc moi je ne cesse de
plaider me suis pas le seul la
gendarmerie en 3d et les crs
depuis des années demande à ce que l'on
positionne comme groupement tactique
tanière un officier supérieur qui lui
vient à sillonner la cohérence tactique
au niveau 2 du terrain dans un secteur
donné en ont géré dans plusieurs unités
y compris les braves alors des
modifications pourraient être mises en
place prochainement plusieurs pistes
sont évoquées
est ce que veulent faire les forces de
l'ordre c'est d'arriver à séparer les
manifestants pacifiques des cafés pour
cela en fait il ya plusieurs choses
ils sont dit il faut faire de la
communication il faut responsabiliser
les manifestants et c'est ce qu'on va
voir dans les prochaines manifestations
je crois notamment y lire à des
policiers qui ne seront plus là pour
contenir les foules ou pour faire du
maintien de l'ordre mais ce seront des
ce qu'on appellera des policiers qui
sont dans des groupes de liaison et
d'information ils vont s'insinuer dans
des groupes de manifestants et ils vont
leur donner des conseils en disant voilà
si vous voulez éviter les problèmes
sachez que devant vous vous avez 20
personnes qui sont des black blocks je
vous conseille de plus tôt vous mettre à
distance parce que il joue de vous comme
d'un bouclier donc le et seydou de 2,2
partir de ne pas rester collés avec
d'autres dispositifs pourraient être
pris notamment pour empêcher à des cafés
reconnu des forces de l'ordre de
participer à des manifestations
christophe castaner alors ministre de
l'intérieur avait essayé de faire
avancer la loi sur ce point puisqu'on
avait appelé la loi anti casseurs et
elle avait été annulée par le conseil
constitutionnel
[Musique]